payez effet collatéral de ce remaniement
la recomposition du centre il ya soir
jean louis borloo a réuni ses amis il
déjeune ce midi avec hervé morin la
famille centriste est elle capable de se
rassembler je ne plonge pas dans les
paniers de crabes a commenté françois
bayrou m et gelos guinée vers une
déclaration pas un mot depuis sa sortie
tonitruante du gouvernement jean louis
borloo s'impose le silence mais en
coulisses il s'attelle à une tâche
difficile le rassemblement des
centristes hier soir ses amis lui ont
confié la mission de défendre les
couleurs du centre au sein de la
majorité
ce qu'on souhaite c'est rétablir un
équilibre dans la majorité le garantir
on as et où l'on se retrouve donc dans
une démarche de projet et aussi avec une
méthode de travail pour se voir
régulièrement pour construire quelque
chose
étape après étape je crois que c'est
c'est ce que nous attendions et personne
de personam met sur sa route jean louis
borloo pourrait bien trouver hervé morin
le président du nouveau centre lui aussi
débarqué du gouvernement ne cache pas
ses ambitions présidentielles pour 2012
de là à parler de rivalité je ne suis
pas en compétition et jean louis borloo
a mis en ligne et enchère florence nous
voulons ensemble examiner tranquillement
sereinement avec la volonté commune de
construire ensemble une force politique
qui a toujours existé en france et y un
message hervé morin et jean louis borloo
déjeunent ensemble à midi le début de
grandes manoeuvres qui suscitent les
railleries de francs par an or s'il n'y
a pas de course au centre parce que
cette course sa nature serait
politicienne et que une démarche
politicienne sur un sujet comme celui là
le tueur et tuerait qui s'imposera donc
au centre à 18 mois de la présidentielle
et alors que l'ump vient
se mettre en ordre de bataille la
planète sans prise est en effervescence